[Applaus]
zuerst haben die man aperitif sehr gern
für meine trauben prosecco und ich nehme
an martini prosecco für die dame für den
herrn einen martin kommt sofort erhalten
so jung vielleicht für mich doch lieber
aperol spritz keinen martini einen
aperol spritz der prosecco für die dame
bleibt ja selbstverständlich
wobei prosecco passte vielleicht nicht
so gut zum fisch oder gehört doch
eigentlich schon eher wissen sie schon
was sie essen möchten ja für meine frau
bitte ein kaltes resort ein kalb tresor
tun was eigentlich kein fisch ist von
daher passt prosecco doch und ich nehme
den gebratenen zander gebratener zander
eine gute wahl salzkartoffeln oder
kroketten dazu
haben wir sicher auch oder vielleicht
doch lieber salzkartoffeln doch lieber
die salzkartoffeln
zu trinken bitte zum trinken dort immer
dann wein oder bier
vielleicht für die dame und wein um für
mich ob wir ein bier für den herrn ein
kleines bier ein kleines kaltes bier
aber vielleicht mit zukunft vielleicht
lieber so raumtemperatur
raumtemperatur und der wahrheit weiß
oder rot ich nehme vielleicht doch auch
lieber nein
zweimal wein weiß oder rot rot weiß
roten vielleicht nicht mehr an bord
mario hatte
einen rio eine gute wahl beim verein
habe ich halt einfach ein sicheres
händchen
polit europa vielleicht nicht so gut zum
zander passt mir nehmen wir doch ein
weißwein
zweimal weißwein darf sein frische
riesling seien frische riesling sehr gut
für mich und riesling und zum volks
resort oder vielleicht doch eher am
rotwein einmal rot einmal weißwein also
dann haben wir für die dame des kalbs
risotto mit dem rio für den herrn das
zanderfilet mit salz körper in einem
studium riesling dazu und als
appetithemmer prosecco und einmal
abgespeckt
zusammengehört dann klavier handy doch
lieber gern an martin
doch lieber einen martini und pommes zum
zander keine salzkartoffeln
nein keine salzkartoffeln
morgen über das gefühl sie hören den so
wichtig zu keine salzkartoffeln sondern
hommes gomez kann ich nur empfehlen ja
seelen dir empfehlungen irgendwie was
durch das alles nicht zusammen jetzt
machen wir sie geben uns bitte noch mit
die karte und wir fangen noch mal ganz
von vorne an was das kommt überhaupt
nicht in frage wir kürzen das ganze
jetzt ab sie und ihre werte gattin
bekommen von mir ein paar wiener wirst
du dazu gibt es aber gerade und eine
apfelschorle vielen dank für die
bestellung
das klingt doch eigentlich gar nicht so
schlecht werden aber bitte die wiener
würstchen mit viel senf und das grau
ausweg bietigheim graut gern
oder doch mit kraut